Much happiness will advise you how to get it but maybe you are not trying
. To be happy, your actions indicate the opposite you want to be
Tired of sailing in the sea of ​​grief - achieving this is very easy
And this video has seven ways to begin to unhappiness - at least
One of them you are doing now, let's start to stay where you are. Stay indoors
As much as possible and preferably in the same room be like a laundry pile
, Do not let a beautiful day tempt you to a picnic .. Avoid everything
Even this mysterious practice keeps good materials away from your mind
Which may help you to improve, and sleep brings you to health problems
Which in turn will remain this cycle revolves, sleep is the most influential thing
An effect you can do, so be like a laundry pile Make your room a place to stay all the time
I live, work, play and sleep in the smallest place possible, and here I come to "tamper with the timing of your sleep"
"Insomnia will be your assistant pilot on your journey in the sea of ​​misery
Quality is not efficient enough, but it helps to get irregular
The productive side of your mind that may lead you
, To happiness in the horizon regularity of sleep something very fragile
It takes at least three days to organize it
Sleep several hours at least twice a week
, And also prefer to be careful to vary the time you wake up go to sleep very late some and not all days
And tell yourself that you are compensating for sleep to feel that you are doing something healthy
Even if you feel tired when you wake up early or late
Irregular sleep helps you in your journey to unhappiness
The more time you sleep, the more difficult it will become
And make your sleep uncluttered and not sleep or wake up at the same time normally
The goal is to help with this "more than one time look at the screens" a great look at the screen helps
Helps previous sailing methods, boredom may push you to move
So let the screens tangle and fatigue may push you to sleep so let the screens keep you awake
As far as possible go always to sleep and screen in your hand
Look at it first when you wake up
Every moment away from the screen you can notice the horizon
Keep your head low and let the events pull you away, and here you have allies you do not know
Behind the screens there are teams of the smartest people and computers competing
They are competing to attract your interest so that they can come to you
You will not be allowed to leave again if you turn away and the screens also help us in advice number four
"Use screens to express your negative feelings" to feed your anger or intolerance to things
For things you do not have authority or influence be aware of everything but do not do anything
Things to care about may lead you out of the sea of ​​blindness
There are reasons to leave your room and do things that are meaningful to the people around you
, But on the contrary you can make things you care about as a source of misery
Focus on the bad side to ship your frustration and frustration and if you have to participate
SHARK participated in a worthless way and was frustrated by the lack of change
We are now approaching the end, and if you follow the steps correctly, unhappiness
Misfortune comes on the way, but part of your mind is trying to change the course of the ship
The ship has a goal and if you are not careful then that part of your mind
Your mind may save you and fortunately we can trick
And a torch leads us deeper into the sea, to achieve the goals must be specific targets and midwives
Achievable, measurable, responsible, and related to a certain time "I will turn the wheel
By one degree now instead of focusing the productive part of your mind on the trivial goals
Make the goal unclear
Make the goal unclear and the road is unclear
To ensure failure, I have cleaned up the whole house today better than
I will wash clothes now, cleaning the whole house is impossible
You will always fail to focus on the goals after what you will achieve
Learn how to shop for a program before you learn how to program
, This will end the productive side of your mind well
Be careful to wait for stimulus rather than plan a specific time to do it
When you feel like you want to do it, you can never do it and with trivial goals
The product part of your mind will be transformed from a serious source of development
Reward yourself every little step you make, into a disgruntled part
A scoundrel cheats you for your failure and for your goal
, At every step in the way and now the petty goals they set
The productive part of your mind may be cooked, but if it continues to resist you
Face to mirage of happiness in the sea of ​​unhappiness and to the islands of happiness
"Immediately after happiness" the human mind will achieve the opposite
When sailing in the direction of happiness
, Imagine happiness as a place where people live there happy happy time all the time
This makes happiness a sense of pleasure that no one can reach
True happiness like a bird may land on your ship, but it will not land if
If you are motivated to hunt it instead of that good from your ship and sail to
To warmer waters, so that the bird will descend while you are not looking ... so do not ever do that
Sail the mirage of happiness instead of improving your ship sailing
Finally the most important but "follow your instincts"
Sailing deeper into the sea of ​​grief is easier because there is
A dark magnetic field leads your connection in the right direction
Once you start you will want to stay indoors, you will not want to
Failure to exercise will be very desirable. Sleep will want to do what you know will make you more sad
Your connection points to the road, both inside and outside
Exterior So follow the real north for your motives and stay away from the other pole
It's all very simple to start with just these tips
And let the sea carry you away ****
This video was produced as a mimicry of Dr Randy Patterson's book How to Become a Miserable
Which is a great example because your thinking is contrary to the goal
It helps you achieve and achieve what you really want and if you want to listen to it
For free you can buy it from aduible.com
Through the free 30 days on site, this site is the best site for audio books
This is the place where I get my audio books from it and you also have to have audiobooks on different types
Audio books, original audio, news, comedy and more if you want
You want to listen to anything that this site has what you want to go to this address
The title for this 30-day free trial is where you can get "how to become miserable" or any other book you want
We summed up seven strategies in the book
But there are 33 other strategies and I am strongly advised to read them all
To find the best one that fits you, Audible is simply the best
You can listen to your books anywhere
I guarantee you will be happy to listen and if you do not like the book you just bought
Simply switch it back, again this is Audible.com/grey
Djerba for 30 days free of charge